[Applause]
i
love everything that you do and i have
to say that i've had the pleasure and
privilege
of seeing you around you are one of the
nicest
most elegant kind wonderful energy
how did you sort of know in the world
to be this person who exudes and conveys
kindness and goodness i mean my mom
really you know instilled an incredible
morals in me when i was younger and i
i don't know i'm just so grateful for
every opportunity that i get
and i'm just innately like a happy
optimistic person
i guess i remember when your book came
out
um and i was so excited because
you know i think you having this
open heart and sharing your experiences
your path your journey with other people
i mean let's get real you have 18
million followers on instagram
when i see that i'm like oh i feel like
they're in such a safe place with you
thank you i i honestly feel so lucky to
have this incredible
community that has surrounded me um on
social media especially instagram
that is so empowering not just to me but
to one another they've created this like
pen pal ship around the world where they
support one another
through things they're going through and
insecurities and i was inspired to write
my book because
of young people around the world sharing
their stories next to their photos it's
like i'm just like you we've all gone
through those things and
whether it's relationships with your
parents yourself um
bad romantic relationships things like
you know body image issues eating
disorders things that i know
so many people can relate to that may
not necessarily
think i can because of you know the
common conception of
of hollywood and the job and the the the
physical aesthetic of the industry and
all that it's like
no actually i can probably relate to
those things way more than you think
that i can
and it's it's ultimately so freeing to
talk about because i feel like i can
just like shed that layer
you know i at least that's what i found
it was a gift for me to
connect with others about those things
you know you grew up
in you know music royalty and
i grew up you know with a last name even
though my family was
gone for a very long time at the point
when
you know in the early 80s when i came on
the scene
but there can be a perception of
what her what are your experiences and
then
i think what ends up happening is in the
best of circumstances
that sort of bubble that may seem like
rather extraordinary and unrelatable
maybe just makes you grow up a little
faster um
makes you open up a little quicker it
kind of makes you get down to business
and reality yeah in a strange way
yeah i totally agree and it's it it gave
me such a drive
to want to feel like i deserved
to be where i am like i you know there's
like a saying where it says personality
can open doors character keeps them open
it's like for a certain amount of time
you know a last name
could be something that's interesting
but at the end of the day
you've got to bring something to the
table and yeah i maybe had to grow up a
little bit quicker
but i was also exposed to the pros and
cons at an early age
and i still chose it for me well you're
a person of such
substance such beauty and such talent
and i'm so excited
about this new project emily
are you kidding me darren starr
who is behind sex in the city and you're
even working with legendary costume
designer patricia field who did
i mean that is like you know i think
aaron does a dream
duo has a great sense of style and we
all admired her style but i feel like it
was the collaboration between her and
patricia field that
catapulted it but what we all loved
about it so much
as you know voyeurs was it's walking art
so i cannot perfectly wait to see your
collaboration with her it's
she's one i mean patricia is just an
absolute icon as you know and she helped
bring out
so much of emily through her clothes and
in turn
i learned so much about myself through
fashion because i think every outfit
brings out a new
point of your personality right and so
um to be bright and bold and a little
bit obvious and sassy and all those
things it just like
made the experience so extra special i
am so
glad that these 19 million people out
there in the world are following
someone like you because i just when i
see a lot of people in one place i'm
always happy that it's with someone
who is a safe safe healthy happy person
like yourself and
that said i know reals are all the rage
now
and i was wondering would you do a reels
with me
i'd be so honored yes i would oh my god
i totally just turned into the biggest
nerd ever
um i can't i just it's uh unfortunately
i can't shed that nerd
at 45. she's still there alive and well
never
shut it never hashtag never shed the
nerd
yeah okay i think uh should we do it
about beauty
i mean yes i'd love to you know what i'd
love to do it
always say to my daughters where is it
important to be pretty and they'll go
the inside and i'm like yeah oh my god
oh my god you're like the best mom
you're like mom goals
okay you're going to ask me some beauty
questions and i'll answer as quickly as
i can because you know it's a real
it's a real and we have to do it real
real fast real sweat fast
okay so how do you perfect dewy skin
without looking too shiny um celestial
skin supernova from flower beauty or
even any moisturizer just boo boo boom
amazing okay how do you perfect a red
lip without messing it up over and over
and over again
um you can always add a little lip balm
and liner
and blotting yes um how do you perfect a
winged eyeliner
um i like to like lift the eye and keep
it really straight and stretched out and
then let it spring back
oh my god i do that too how do you avoid
cakey makeup definitely throw
even if it's misted water from a sink
that you put in your hands or a little
moisturizer don't add more
like add dewyness not more makeup and
then spot treat
audrey is the key i'm so all about that
okay last one how do you brighten your
tired eyes
oh sleep
that's a really good one i feel like
everyone could do with more of that oh
my god i love these
oh i love you emily in paris season one
is on netflix now and she's uh
co-hosting the gala for the go campaign
on october 24th
and by the way excuse me i didn't mean
to bury the lead
congratulations on your engagement
[Applause]
is he lovely and kind yeah good
yes yes i'm i'm the luckiest
i'm so grateful and i just i truly feel
like
the happiest i've ever been so i'm i'm
very very lucky
thank you lily i can't wait to see thank
you
[Music]
you